is this thing a tool or ultimately is it
a human replacement system artificial
intelligence has dominated headlines
this week our main stories tonight
concerns artificial intelligence or AI
artificial intelligence is getting
pretty crazy in the world of creativity
it's all the rage I've been wanting to
have a conversation about uh chat GPT
chat GPT chat chat is poised to change
the way we interact with computers and
AI but there are also warnings about the
huge risk of misuse recent advances in
artificial intelligence are already
reshaping the Work World how long until
the machines replace us take our jobs
anyone who writes for a living has to be
concerned this is going to put a lot of
artists out of work well look that Alpha
grind product is all over Tick Tock if
you go to Amazon I'm just gonna pause it
there that's not Joe Rogan talking
that's insane